- Hi, everyone! Sal Khan here.
Just to remind everyone that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
That means I don't own Khan Academy,
no one owns Khan Academy,
we are a public charity.
And we can only do the work we do
through donations from
folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making a donation.
As a reminder,
Khan Academy is about the
budget of a large high school,
but we try to reach all of humanity.
And last year,
we had 13 billion learning
minutes on the platform.
Half of that are students and
families all over the world,
oftentimes telling us that
this is a learning resource,
the tutor, the help that their family
could not otherwise afford.
The other half is hundreds of thousands
of teachers using Khan
Academy in the classroom
to personalize learning,
to make it more engaging,
for them to have better information
about where their kids are,
so that they can do more focus
interventions with students.
There's some calculations
around social return.
In the for-profit sector,
if you've got even a 20 or
30% return on investment,
that's considered a
very, very good return.
In the not-for-profit sector,
if you get even a 2X or
3X benefit to cost ratio
for a not-for-profit,
that's considered very good.
Even conservative estimates
of Khan Academy are 500 to one
to a thousand to one benefit.
Because we're at a special time in history
where something like education,
which has always been scarce
and frankly always been expensive,
at least aspects of it,
very important aspects of it
can now be delivered to tens of millions,
hundreds of millions of people
in ways that we could not have imagined
even 20 or 30 years ago.
And as I tell everyone,
as much as Khan Academy has done
over the last 10 or 12 years,
and as much as we've done this past year,
especially during the pandemic,
we're just getting started.
We really wanna cover all of
the core academic subjects
from pre-K through the core of college.
We wanna meet students where they are,
and we wanna think about how
do we connect that learning
to real opportunity, whether
it's getting into college,
getting a job, or getting
credit in some way.
And we wanna do it one day
for billions of people around the world.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making a contribution
of any size to Khan Academy.
It will go a long, long way.